we did a segment a couple of weeks ago
where we talked about how the smartphone
revolution has really allowed people to
live more minimalistic lives right you
can get rid of so much stuff and we had
this long list you could get rid of your
computer you can get rid of your alarm
clock you can get rid of your notepads
and pieces of paper for making notes you
can get rid of your calendar agenda
whatever you would call it you can get
rid of your address book etc etc and
there's been a big sort of a lot of
people emailed me saying they absolutely
agreed with what I was saying and then
some people emailed me and they said
that they absolutely disagree with what
I'm saying and then there were people
who were sort of in the middle so today
I want to explore some of the
counter-arguments would we we would we
be better off without smartphones
altogether there's been a lot of
articles written about this there's been
interesting discussions on online forums
including Reddit and so many other
places why might we be better off
without smartphone technology and one
issue that always comes to the top of
the list louis is this expectation for
and need for constant stimulation that
many people feel as a result of their
phone it's harder to just sit around
doing nothing if you do have a moment
where you would otherwise be doing
nothing you get your phone and you look
at something you read what the last five
people have posted on your Facebook page
or you read a news article or you play a
game or whatever and then the other sort
of issue or argument that goes
hand-in-hand with this is that
smartphones reduce opportunities to
really think about things because you
can just look them up you're sitting
around with some friends oh does gravity
bend light well we could all sit around
and think about it or I could just
instantly look it up on my phone whereas
maybe before smart phones yeah you could
look it up online but you've got to go
upstairs and turn your computer on and
get logged in and look it up but now you
do there's just no opportunity you
instantly look it up on your phone right
away when you're driving I don't get
lost anymore right I mean yes in Boston
sometimes even with GPS you end up in a
tunnel as opposed to on a bridge and
then you're out of town but the GPS
would know right away exactly how to get
back I used to have to sometimes think
about okay
I have my printed directions to go from
A to B but I ended up at spot C so I've
got to get back on my path maybe that is
something that is good for human brains
to be lost sometime or whatever what's
your general reaction to some of these
arguments that are made well we probably
are losing something yes by having all
of this information readily available at
our fingertips but imagine where we
would be without any of it right so I'm
for it I don't think we're better off
without it and perhaps there will be a
tipping point where where we realize
things have gone too far and and there
might be some type of movement to kind
of bring us back down I mean let's to go
through the first issue that I mentioned
the idea that we're now craving constant
stimulation and whatever yeah it's true
that sort of scrolling on your
smartphone does release dopamine in a
way that's reminiscent of using other
substances or other activities in that
sense however sometimes you see these
pictures of oh everybody on the subways
on their smartphones but then you see
pictures from the 60s where everybody
has their head down in a newspaper so is
that really different because it's a
smartphone instead of a newspaper I
don't know I guess you sort of have to
be the judge of that some people just
can't sit still and observe what's
happening around them right they just
happen to be looking at the cell phone
so it's it you might find it annoying
you might not enjoy being in the company
of these people but if it wasn't the
cell phone like you said it would be a
newspaper it would be something else or
they yeah does that make sense it does
and as far as the you know less
opportunities for really thinking about
things I would make a counter argument
which is when you're sitting around with
people and the topic comes up like for
example does gravity bend light yes
you're not spending as much time
thinking about whether gravity bends
light you're instantly able to look that
up on your phone but maybe that allows
you more time to actually think about
concepts where you can't look up the
answer right you can get past the facts
and
move on to the ideas more quickly I
don't know I mean I'm just sort of
thinking out loud here when you think
about how what is the impact on society
biddin of the fact that now we have
instantaneous communication yeah you
don't need to spend time debating or
wondering when was the telephone
developed and in what year was TV
developed right you have those facts
available to you instantly but maybe you
get past the facts and then you can
really get into talking about how these
technologies have affected you or
someone else so I don't I don't know I
mean yes you don't spend as much time
just trying to remember fact that's true
but you could make the argument that
that opens up the door to more time
spent on other types of thought true but
here we are and we have the cell phones
everybody has a smartphone and it makes
life much easier for us and at this
point if you were just to take the
smartphones away people would find
something new to waste time on well that
but we would we would find ourselves at
a disadvantage so it would have to be
for us to just get rid of them or find
that we don't need to use them there
would have to be a fundamental shift of
things and there is sort of a pragmatic
reality here which is if you just decide
for yourself you are no longer going to
have a smartphone at all and everybody
else still does you're probably actually
making yourself worth soph in a lot of
ways I know some people that don't have
smartphones and they have to sort of
remind me remind me when we have a
meeting set listen when I leave my house
I am not going to have any access to
communication other than if you call me
so you're gonna have to make a phone
call because remember if you send me a
text my phone doesn't get text and if
you email me I don't I don't have that
etc etc if everybody else is connecting
in this way as an individual to remove
yourself from that is definitely going
to have some consequences you can't
really act unilaterally many people do I
mean from a literal perspective you can
but there are consequences to that that
are different than if society said we're
gonna pair down the smartphone stuff
mm-hmm we're stuck and it gets it's
getting worse the bad things are getting
worse the good things simultaneously are
getting better but in the future we are
probably going to see some very fierce
anti-technology campaigns and movements
there have there's been a lot of writing
in science fiction over the last 15
years about hypothetical future
societies that have gone the complete
opposite way in the no technology
direction sort of a return to I mean
it's almost like a modern I mean I know
Amish still exist but it's sort of like
a new Amish type movement of conserving
a past sort of status quo and that's
been written about extensively in a lot
of sci-fi literature it's it's
inevitable people will try it we
wouldn't be able to do our jobs if we
went that route but every movement has a
counter movement at some point I think
so interesting
very very interesting